Key Technical Matters: Business Gifts
Characteristics of a great business gift, in descending order: ...
...Thoughtful, difficult to acquire, expensive, extremely large.
Connotations of a great business gift, in descending order:
Thank you.
It's great being your partner.
Please.
I'm begging you here.
I spent hours whittling your likeness into a piece of oak.
No gift cards.
No coupons for "Free hugs to be redeemed at any time."
Anything with your company's logo on it is not a gift.
A promotional watch is not a gift.
A promotional shirt is not a gift.
A promotional pen is not a gift.
A promotional stress relief hand globe is absolutely not a gift.
It's also not an effective weapon against stress.
At the end of the day, an employee only really wants one kind of gift:...
...a day off.
Investors only want one kind of gift, too:...
...a return...
...and maybe an interesting bottle of whiskey.
Oh, what the hell, maybe throw in a couple of those shirts for the kids,...
...but mostly, a return.